hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys suggested from round one
of the tata still tournament 2022. it's
youngshish of duda uh the candidates for
the next candidates tournament uh versus
rihard rapport and it's uh well it's
quite the game a lot of people say that
it's a reminiscent of um a famous game
played by nigel short but we will see
what happens so that being said let's
check it out a duda with the white
pieces opens with d4 uh we have knight
to f6 knight to f3 d5 and the bishop to
f4 another london system is on the board
and you can counter this uh well many
different ways but here a wrapper goes
for bishop to f5 so the symmetrical
variation
and now c4 and this is also a fine
example of how symmetry in chess never
works uh just for fun we're going to
show what happens if black continues uh
playing symmetrical c character c
captures we're going to play queen
captures on the four queen captures on
the e5 knight to c3 knight to c6 and now
of course knight captures on d5
knight captures on d4 and knight to c7
check a check always breaks symmetry in
check because now of course knight to c2
is impossible we have to move the king
and after the king moves we pick up the
knight knight captures here and then the
bishop is hanging and well uh white is
just up a piece but a nice example of
wine it never works so here e6 we have
e3 and now knight b to d7 and now there
are a couple of moves that were played
in this position knight to c3 being the
most popular one but here queen to b3 uh
is a new move so as of move six we have
a completely new game uh duda is
attacking the b7 pawn but rapper not
interested in that please bishop the d6
now the the the idea is that if bishop
captures on d6 we're first going to
capture the pawn on c4 and now let's say
queen captures on b7 we're going to play
c captures on e6 and we have a very nice
center here uh of course bishop captures
on c4 will be played now rook b8 and
after the queen moves we're going to
pick up the b2 pawn and black has quite
uh
nicely developed his pieces and well he
doesn't really have anything to worry
about so instead after bishop d6 with
bishop back to g3 a nice standard
retreat um
in the london and now we have a d
captures on c4 so the queen is attacked
the shop captures on c for putting a lot
of pressure on this diagonal and now
rook to b8 here it upper place rook to
b8 nuts to defend the b7 pawn uh but to
try and uh give it up so here knight to
c3 and of course b5
uh point being that if you capture on b5
we're just gonna play captures captures
in a6 and the knight is lost
so after b5 we have bishop back to e2
and now uh we have castles and rook to
d1
uh so what can you play of course we're
just going to continue developing queen
to a7 uh the connecting rooks and now
knight the e5 and this is always uh
uh well an annoying piece for black to
handle because you can never capture
with the knight usually you have a
knight on f6 and bishop here if you
capture with the knight then you just
lose material and you kind of don't want
to give up this bishop for a night
but you also have to so here we have b4
very interesting and now comes night
or rather uh here knight's day four was
played but uh
rapper is also allowing duda to play
knight to c6 the fork the queen and the
rook and if this happens uh this is what
rappers had in mind and it's just uh
amazing b captures on c3 so
not only does he give up the queen but
he gives up the queen with check so the
knight captures an e7 with check
bishop captures an e7 and now it doesn't
matter what you do if you capture on c3
then rapper wins the queen back with
queen to b4
or if you play something like queen to
c4 then he you can play c2 attack the
rook and after something like rook to c1
you can pick up the b2 pawn it's just a
beautiful beautiful position for black
and black most certainly has
compensation for the queen so it would
be a very uh well exciting rapport uh
type of position uh but okay knights to
a4 duda doesn't go for this crazy line
and now bishop captures an e5 d captures
and now knight to e4 putting pressure on
this bishop but
here duda just forces that so here f3
the king will be safe on f2 so it's not
a problem knight captures here h
captures on g3 and now knight to c5 and
now after captures and captures uh it
seems black nicely equalized and has no
worry in the world uh
for the moment so here king f2 uh not
only adding more protection to the e3
pawn but also connecting your rooks and
the queen captures an e5
uh we have rook to d7 now uh uh
preparing to double up on the d file it
seems like you could also try doubling
up on the h file but with black having a
light square bishop it just doesn't seem
like uh it's all that uh impressive so
here a5 defending our pawn on b4 and now
rook h to d1
we have h5
and now e4 chasing away the bishop we
have bishop to g6 and now rook 1 to d2
adding more protection to the b2 pawn
we have h4 g captures on h4 queen to h2
now getting ready to pick up the h4 pawn
and now bishop to f1 so setting up a
defense on the king side queen captures
an h4 g3 and now you could go here but
uh
once the king moves the queen will also
have to move so queen h5 ended now queen
to e3
and now uh well it's just not easy for
black to to find the move uh you could
you should probably try to open up the
position with f5 since the
uh well you you have to try to attack
the black king but here at upper the
plays on the queen side he plays c5 now
king the g2 now the bishop can move so
the queen no longer
can access the king side we have a4
and now bishop to c for setting up a
blockade on the queen side we have a3
and b3 and i'll look at this the queen
side completely blocked the d file the
only open file on the board or rather
okay the h file is also open but the the
d file
is completely in white control uh you
are never putting anything on that d8
square to challenge white rooks and what
can what can black do here well uh queen
to e5 you can't go here or here to guard
the d8 square to place a rook to d8 so
here we have queen to e5 now maybe try
and queen f6 the gain control over of
the d8 square but now queen f4 duda says
that's not happening we're trading
queens and i keep all the control on the
queen side and in the center of the
board so here queen capture spawn
captures and now bishop to h5 so king to
g3
we have g6 and now rook
2 to d3 also guarding this pawn because
now duda is preparing a nice king march
so here we have rook beta e8 there is
not much that black can do here white is
just stronger on the queen side on the
king side and in the center of the board
king h4 we have king to g7 not allowing
this white king to go all the way to f6
but it doesn't matter king to g5 we rook
to h8 and now rook to c7
attacking this pawn
so here we defended rook the c8 rook the
e7 and now rook c back to e8 trying to
trade a pair of rooks so rook back to d7
and now rook h to f8 so uh how can how
can do the make progress here uh he
tries again rook to c7 and now uh
rapporteur doesn't repeat with rook to
c8 he actually plays rook to h8 here
rapport sets a little trap for duda
because if duda captures the c5 pawn uh
then we just capture on f3 and we just
win this position it's now much better
for black it doesn't matter really what
you do because you're either losing the
e4 pawn or if you capture the bishop
then rook h5 checking you for rook
captures and c5 will be winning for
black so instead after rook h8 duda just
doubles up on the d on the seventh rank
and then now we have rook h to f8 uh and
uh we've reached move 40 so time control
has been reached but white is completely
winning so uh feel free to pause the
video here in the windows position for
duda while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on always going for
that breakthrough at the exact
appropriate moment and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course pawn to f5
uh this is uh this is what was played in
the game and it was in this position on
move 41 that rihan rapport resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so the thing is you can't really capture
with anything if you capture with this
pawn then this pawn falls and then
everything falls apart you could capture
with this pawn but then the bishop is
hanging you don't even have to capture
gameplay he captures an f5 and if bishop
captures here if captures an e6 black
cannot capture this with anything it
just the complete the position just
falls apart and if you try something
like uh maybe moving the rogue rook to
d8 we can just trade captures captures f
captures and e6 and again the entire
position just falls apart so there is
absolutely no move rapper can make here
and that's why uh
he resigned here
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it the very very nicely played
we will see if we can uh cover another
game before the start of round two as
there are a couple of other nice games
that we can cover uh i would like to
thank andrew dinihan link mike wagner uh
joseph henderson and frank holmes for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
tata steel chess tournament until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day